I saw this busy board on TikTok shop and as a homeschool mum
I was interested.
So here I'm testing out with my one year old son.
He was very attracted to the toy
and was engaged in playing with it for a few minutes.
Up next is my four year old daughter.
She has ADHD and loses focus pretty quickly.
She loved this toy and was engaged in it for several minutes.
I did take it away from her,
she wasn't done.
But I did give it to my 7 year old son.
He was very interested in it and wanted to know how it all worked.
I could see this being really useful while travelling
on aeroplane and public transport.
Really did perform on all age groups and they were all interested.
Later on in the evening
I gave it to my son again when I was breastfeeding
and it did stop him from twiddling